we have seen a lot of things get kind of
wacky and backwards in the aftermath of
joe biden pulling troops from
afghanistan and of course that created a
vacuum in which the taliban has retaken
control of the country now i'm not going
to redo yesterday's segment where i
outlined my position on this in full but
in short i agree with joe biden's
decision i said this yesterday i think
there would have been chaos whenever we
ultimately left afghanistan
but the afghanistan incursion has been a
failure a more u.s involvement for more
time wouldn't help anything the longer
we stay the more money is spent to
ultimately achieve nothing our
involvement is a negative it's not a
positive
and one of the things that we're seeing
is all sorts of people on the left on
the right for different reasons now say
we have to go back into afghanistan
that's one thing we're seeing there's
all of a sudden people saying no we got
to go back it was a mistake to leave
we've got to do more nation building and
peacekeeping and world policing and all
this stuff let's go back in that's weird
but another of the strange things we're
seeing and i'm not even saying i know
what to make of it but another thing
we're seeing is some really bizarre kind
of like revisionist histories
and apologizing for the taliban which
has now taken control now i will be the
first to admit
the taliban
is more complicated than just like one
explanation like sharia law
okay well yeah i mean sharia law can
mean different things in different
countries but
there are now
some people framing the taliban as sort
of like maybe kind of good and i'm
finding it really weird and today we're
going to look at a clip of british chief
of defense staff general sir nick carter
that's actually his title i'm not like
doing the sur routine uh general sir
nick carter who was on sky news talking
about kind of like the taliban's not
that bad
and so let's just get into it check out
the words he uses and how he describes
the taliban now carter was in
afghanistan in 2004 commanding british
troops there had additional deployments
to afghanistan and remember the taliban
is a radical group considered a
terrorist group by multiple governments
including canada turkey and others the
u.s has never recognized the taliban
government although i don't believe the
u.s considers the taliban a terrorist
group
trump was just negotiating with them
months ago so here we go let's take a
look and uh check this out and how do
you feel about collaborating with the
enemy when um they have carried out such
atrocities against um uk military
personnel over the years i think you
have to be very careful using the word
enemy
i think people need to understand who
the taliban actually are and of course
what they are a disparate collection of
tribes people as president karzai put it
to me only yesterday they're country
boys
and the plain fact is that they happen
to live by a code of honor so
these are these are tribes people
they're country boys
and they live by a code of honor almost
implying like that's a good thing
on its face now code of honor code of
honor can be anything you could have a
code of honor that is uh horrifying and
there are many examples of that uh but
he continues to sort of say this is not
this is maybe not so bad of a group
understand it which has been their
standard for many many years it's called
pashtun wally it has honour at the heart
of what they do they are bound together
by a common purpose which is they don't
like corrupt governance they don't like
governance that is self-serving and they
want an afghanistan that is inclusive
for all wow i mean that that's sounding
pretty good right i mean it's all about
honor these are country boys
they're very much against corruption
well corruption's bad so being against
corruption must be good
and they're for inclusion i mean that
that's all pretty good stuff right now
while in power in afghanistan when you
look at the history the taliban became
notorious
for their misogyny and their violence
against women period forcing full burka
wearing at all at all times systematic
gender segregation
women not allowed to work women not
allowed to be educated past age eight
only allowed to go to a male doctor if
they have a male chaperone to take them
public floggings and executions for
women for violating taliban law
occasionally forcing into child marriage
and on and on and on so maybe he's
saying it would be different now or
something but but we don't actually have
reason to think that that's the case so
let's continue here so i think rather
than talking about that
what except women um well again i think
we have to wait and see i mean i don't
know what they mean i can't support the
way that they treat women
surely well i think you have to listen
to what they're saying at the moment and
i think you have to listen to the facts
on the ground they're saying they are
definitely
what they're saying is using this coded
language about the involvement of women
in society
uh as dictated by religious law right
and so you have to be you have to
understand uh that that's an
extraordinarily cynical way to talk
about inclusion oh yeah and i'm not
saying that's anything that you and i
would approve of particularly just but i
do find that absolutely but i do and
i'll go back just a second because
sharia law is mentioned here acts on the
ground they are definitely back
yeah and i'm not saying that's anything
that you and i would approve of
particularly just but i do find that
absolutely but i do think that they have
changed i think they recognize that over
the course the last 20 years afghanistan
has evolved they recognize the
fundamental role that women have played
in that evolution and yes they at the
moment will undoubtedly say that they
want to respect women's rights under
islamic law and that will be a sharia
law but that doesn't necessarily mean
that they won't allow them to be
involved in government and in education
and in medicine and those things that
they need them to be involved in now
i i don't want to just slam this guy
like the there is there's an aspect of
this that i think
you know we i am not for sharia law i'm
not for any
religious law being the government law
civil law okay like no matter what it is
i don't want the christian version of
sharia that some of these right-wingers
want in the u.s i don't i'm against
sharia law but if we're going to have a
more nuanced understanding of this
sharia can mean different things in
different places and we have to
understand that like for example there's
full sharia criminal law which is
outrageous i mean just completely
outrageous
there's also
sharia law like in egypt okay where
the penal and civil codes are basically
based on 19th century french law as in
the as is the case in many parts of the
world
um but but there is sharia law uh in the
country um uh it in some more general uh
religious uh kind of mix with the
government but the the penal code the
civil law uh is still is still based on
19th century french law so the point
here is
it's true that sharia law is not one
thing
but there's no reason to think based on
the history of the taliban
that um they would go in the direction
of egypt historically the taliban has
gone more in the direction of full
sharia criminal law
let's let's look just the last few
seconds of this clip
so i think we have to be patient we have
to give them the space to show how they
are going to step up to the plate and
whether or not we can work with them
will very much depend upon how they
treat all afghans okay so it's sort of
just like a weird soft apologetics for
the taliban and this is just one example
and to be clear i'm not saying the
taliban's bad so we got to send troops
in no i'm glad the troops are coming out
even though some now went back in we
talked about that yesterday uh but some
of the weird apologetics that we're
seeing for the taliban absent any reason
to think that the taliban has really
changed i just find bizarre so i want to
hear from you about this we're going to
have more coverage of this story on the
david pakman show instagram which you
can find at david pakman show while
you're there you can also follow me on
instagram at
david.pakman if you ever feel like you
just don't have enough time to read all
the books you want to read you have to
check out one of my favorite apps called
blinkist blinkist takes thousands of
popular nonfiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book just
imagine how you'll be able to expand
your horizons and knowledge by being
able to soak up all of the important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon obviously it's perfect for
exposing yourself to a new book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for or you
can use it to revisit a book you've
already read or use it to preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video